overwhelming pain as families are called
to identify their relatives it was after
midnight when police say more than a
dozen people were shot dead by gunmen in
a bar near johannesburg
bodies piled near the entrance are
victims who tried to run out and escape
what we know is that the assailants they
just entered into that space while
people enjoying themselves and they shot
randomly to them
investigators have described the
shooting as a massacre
it sends us that
anyone now who possesses a gun wants to
try their can
on our communities
and we have to call upon communities to
actually really indeed assist the police
in bringing to book those perpetrators
police say nothing was stolen from the
business
now their focus turns on catching those
responsible and finding out why the
victims were targeted
al jazeera
well the attack comes just hours after
another shooting in eastern south africa
four people were killed during a
shootout at a bar in peter maritzburg
eight others were injured
earlier i spoke to william gumede he's
the executive chairperson of the
democracy works foundation and was also
deputy editor of the soweto newspaper he
says south africa needs to get a handle
on gun violence
what is very clear is south africa's
culture of violence we you know we've
been unable to tackle our culture of
violence and secondly our culture of
guns and and weapons you know guns
are freely available um in the country
and because the country comes from a
history of both state violence and then
anti-apartheid movement violence and we
also we have cultures that are very
violent and you bring it together with
guns um in
free circulation and then you know
thirdly a lack of effective policing in
the country brings us this really a
terrifying violent mix that we are very
announcing in the country so as you're
saying shooting is not uncommon uncommon
in the country i mean give us a sense of
what uh they're linked to
and um also how big a problem gun crime
is in the country and particularly
perhaps in soweto where this latest
shooting took place
you know
a gun crime really is a a very big
problem in our country um we also have
the other circumstances that our borders
are poorly policed so you know so
there's also influx of illegal guns and
and weapons um from outside of south
africa and then you combine it also
you know to already freely available
guns um in south africa so guns are
often used
um with knives in certain parts of the
country um as part of crime and that
distinguished you know the crime in
south africa which is often very violent
this is often accompanied
with guns does the other thing about
guns also um sadly it is also you know
some parts of our societies become part
of you know people's identity you know
sense of power and and the machoness
linked to guns has become both in black
communities and white many of white
communities have become so guns have
become part of the identity
of people and we've been unable to this
associate guns um with the identity
particularly male identity often in the
country
so where does the failure lie in
not being able to tackle this issue and
what would you like to see done
you know the first part of the failure
of course is just
you know lack of policing and a
breakdown of the rule of law in the
country so that you know it becomes a
government failure you know the failure
of the government firstly to take the
rule of law seriously because um you
know rule of law um impact on the
country across whether from an economic
point of view from a growth point of
view from a job's point of view um and
so the agency government has not
actually seen i think the seriousness of
a rule of law for the stability of the
country secondly is also the society
must have a conversation with itself um
you know around guns um and around
violence and that we really have to make
the use of violence uh we must make it
um
not part of the society
um
you know items distance itself um from
guns and from violence as the way to
deal with problems